that precision so we have good afternoon
so find it a bit embarrassing to give to
elections and - public optimization in
countries origins but so especially
because many of you know much more than
I do about this the subject but I'll try
to do my best and certainly I will keep
it
Elementary so so far even though I
missed because of a flight cancellation
I missed the talks yesterday it seems
that you've been mostly dealing with
stable polynomials and we unstable and
so on and so I first want to define
hyperbolic polynomials and study some of
their own properties so I'll be dealing
with polynomials multivariate
polynomials P of which we own
polynomials
and I will mostly be I will be only
dealing with am a genius polynomials of
degree D meaning that P of alpha X alpha
D T to the X if I have such a polynomial
I'd say that P is and I should say that
most of the things that I'm going to be
saying many of the things originated in
the wonk of Golding in 50s with more
recent things by some of the people in
this audience and so let me first define
what is hyperbolic polynomial so P
is hyperbolic in direction D in n with D
not a zero of P so P of D nonzero if
from all X if I look at the univariate
polynomial which is P of X plus TD oh
yes right I'm sorry that's a good point
thank you thank you for telling me at
this point so I would have noticed it at
some point and so it's it's good that
you mentioned it right now so let me
call the direction e so E is not
necessarily all all one's vectors and
direction so T X plus GE if this is as
we own if this as only real roots
so I give you a relation with stability
probably a bit later but let me now
define it that way in fact I will
sometimes look at this polynomial and
sometimes I will look at P of X minus GE
so generally it's the same condition and
I will call these real these real roots
we typically call them lambda 1 of X and
2 effects and so on and since it's a
polynomial which is homogeneous of
degree D so that would be lambda D of X
now notice that to be to be precise I
should say that it's in the direction so
let me give you some example so let me
start with the most basic example and
that's P of X which is the product of
the X buys I 1 to N and and let's say
the direction e is the it's all one or
one victim
so clearly in that case P of X minus te
is the product of the X sub I is minus T
sub i's and XXI minus T and so the the
roots on the roots are the exabytes so
that's so that see that is hyperbolic
and and it's actually hyperbolic not
just in that direction but running them
but it's hyperbolic in any e which is in
the positive octant
so that's a very basic example let me
generalize this a tiny bit we could also
look at P FX is for example the product
of a bunch of linear so L sub I is
linear in X and so in that case what is
on lynnium and so in that case also we
have that if I look at P of X minus te
so and I would take an e which is not a
not a zero of this so such that a lie of
E is nonzero from every every time so I
would also get a hyperbolic
and give you another example let me take
P of X is X and squirmin - the sum over
I want to n minus 1 of the X I squint
and let me take as direction e to be the
direction that's more zeros except the
last coordinate being 1 and so for
example in in 1 n when n is let's say 3
would be the following if that this is
let's say X 3 so the if you look at the
zeros of this you get
you get so these on the this and so if I
take if I take any if I take as my
direction
0:01 if I take any X and I look at in
the direction of x3 if I look at the
univariate polynomial along this line so
clearly so that's a quadratic polynomial
and it will have two two roots more
generally in n dimensions that's also
hyperbolic why is that so if I look at P
of X minus e I get that that's xn minus
T squared minus the sum I 1 to n minus 1
of X ice queen so that's T squared minus
twice X n t plus xn square minus sum
over I up to n minus 1 if I squint and
so the discriminant is discriminant is
going to be 4 X 1 n minus 4 X 1 n plus
plus this
it's ice cream so it's the system and
indeed that's non-negative so that as
only we onwards so these are two very
basic example a more interesting example
is if I look at symmetric matrices and I
look at them as victims in in dimension
and n plus 1 over 2 so representing a
symmetric matrix and I look at P of X
which is the determinant of the
corresponding symmetric matrix so this
is a bit of abuse of notation but you
saw me understand what it means and I
take as my direction - bollocks
direction what corresponds to the
identity so in that case what is P of X
minus te it's just the determinant of x
minus TI and since that is a symmetric
so by big X I mean the matrix X so since
that's a symmetric matrix eigenvalues we
own so that's the characteristic
polynomial so that's also a very basic
example so we could do that also we
could do the same thing over complex
hermitian matrices
we not discuss that too much let's do
another example let's look at a P of X
which is the determinant and that's one
of the most important example determined
of so the variables are X 1 up to X n so
X I times a I for the a sub i's
symmetric matrices and and let me for
now let's let's take a direction e such
that the corresponding matrix sum over I
of e I a I s is the identity so if if
that's if that's the case then again P
of X minus te is just the determinant of
the sum over I of X I minus T by minus T
AI times die which is the determinant of
the some I of X i AI minus T the
identity and again I have the
characteristic polynomial and so it's
and I could have done the same thing if
instead of having such a II I have an e
such that the sum of I of a I AI is
positive definite so if it is positive
definite then I can also in that case I
get T times that and I can pull out the
square root of that and get also the
characteristic polynomial okay let's do
a more communitarian example that we
also saw this morning and it looks like
maybe yesterday as well so let's take
the spanning-tree polynomial of a of a
graph G so by that I mean that we look
at the sum over all spanning trees let
me maybe denote by that by B so these
are the spanning trees
he and B of the product from the
elements in T of X I and as we saw this
morning we can use we can use the co
ship in a formula for example to show
that this is hyperbolic let's take the
direction of hyperbola City let's take
that to be the old one victim so one
over all the edges of the graph and one
way to show that this is this is
hyperbolic is to show that is to use the
Kim cuffs matrix three theorem which
says that P G of X is the same thing as
the determinant of the sum over all and
so I'm going to reuse III Sasha but over
on the edges II so that's a different
even this e over the edges E or maybe
edges I okay fine x AI x li but that
doesn't look good so e le when L e is
the the laplacian corresponding to edgy
except that to make it so what Cheyenne
had done this morning was to get rid of
I mean to add 1 1 transpose but you can
just get rid all so a row so so it's
so
so in which you just get rid of one row
of the laplacian matrix and watch ion
are shown as well let me redo it just
for the sake of completeness so now that
it's in this form you see that it's
precisely of of this form and so that's
that's hyperbolic in in any direction
from which you get that this is positive
definite and for example if you put all
one Sundy on the edges you get the sum
of all the Laplace Union so if the graph
is connected that's going to be positive
definite so another way of doing it is
to use the coachee Bunnell formula that
Shane mentioned this morning so what you
can do in that case you can look at the
matrix M which is a V minus 1 times e
matrix so it's indexed by the columns
the rows I index by all all wrong keys
except 1 and the columns I indexed by
all edges and then so you take you you
take that incidents that adjacency
matrix except that you remove one go and
then the claim is that PG of X
is simply the the determinant of M times
a diagonal matrix which is unknowns X
times M transpose and the way to see
that is to use the so that so you have a
product of a matrix times itself times
another matrix and you take the
determinant and so by Cauchy Benet
that's going to be the this is equal to
the sum over all subsets of size V minus
1 so over all subsets T of size V minus
1 of the determinant of M restricted to
that subset can you see that lo no
probably not actually
and and so then the the product of these
edges in T of X P and then times the
determinant of M transpose restricted to
these to these elements so that's also
the same thing as this so that's just
this squared that will save me some
space and the crucial thing is that the
determinant of M T so since this matrix
M is totally unimodal um so totally in
modular matrix meaning that every sub
matrix every square matrix has
determined you know 0 1 or minus 1 so
it's 0 when this is when this as a as a
cycle and so it's going to take to be 1
or minus 1 precisely when T is a
spanning tree and so that's going to be
reducing to the sum over all spanning
trees of the product over the variables
over on that spanning tree so that shows
that this is that the spanning tree
polynomial corresponding to any graph is
actually hyperbolic in that direction so
this could have been the same thing if
instead of saying the spanning tree
polynomial I had said I take a the basis
of a regular Metroid
so what is a regular metrid it's just a
Maitre D' which can be represented can
be represented over any field and in
particular another way of defining it is
that it's a metric that can be
represented by a totally in unimodular
matrix so if in that case I mean it's
there is no graph so this is to take a
regular basis of a regular Metroid and
so in that case you get that you're
summing over all so that's the matrix
that represents that's a totally
unimodular matrix that represents the
independence in that regular Metroid and
then when you take when you take that
polynomial you get that you get that you
sum over all bases in regular matrix of
this which is in so it's zero if it's
not a basis and it's one or minus one if
it is a basis so that gives you a 1 and
and and so you get that P of X as such a
representation but such a representation
is precisely the same thing as this
example 5 namely it's the sum the
determinant of determinant of these sum
of I of X I M I and my transpose
okay so the assumption is it's regular
and that implies that this matrix is
totally right so a so you can define
regular matrix in different ways one way
one one typical definition is that a
regular metroid so-and-so definition is
a regular metroid it can be the williams
by a totally union modular matrix or not
own definition that's one definition not
on definition which is equivalent is
that it can be represented can be
represented or any field
that's so the graphic Metroid
corresponding to spanning trees is a
regular Metroid so that was a few
examples of hyperbolic gnomes behind
okay I was hoping so but so let me now
define the hyperbolic cone so if I have
a hyperbolic polynomial I can define I
can associate it with it a hyperbolic
cone
and that's the set k+ which is so that
depends on the polynomial P let's say
it's the set of X in RN plus in RN such
that the corresponding roots so we know
that if we go in the direction
II we have only real roots and so we'd
like the roots these real roots to be
positive so lambda I I so that's that's
what is defined as the hyperbolic cone
so that's one definition for example if
I take if I take this example this three
dimensional example and I take this e
then you can see that it's going to be
the in Timonium of J so that's the ice
cream code on the second autumn code and
let's see let's let's and and one one
obvious property of it is that so one
basic fact is that the direction e
belongs to the hyperbolic code why is
that it's simply because if I look at
the polynomial in E and I subtract GE
since its am a genius that's 1 minus T
to the D times PE and so the roots will
be all equal to 1 and so definitely the
all positive so he belongs to in fact I
mean it's so let's see what it gives
from all the examples that we saw from
the first example for example 1
as we peel I'm assuming that PFE is
non-0
I was not assuming I mean it doesn't
really matter and you could assume it or
you I mean it's becoming now important
whether you're adding subtract wait so
in my definition of lambda eyes and my
definition of lambda eyes I'm
subtracting in my definition of lambda I
so it's the the the root of P of X minus
T it doesn't really matter in terms of
the definition of hyperbolic City so
it's if it is hyperbolic I mean if it
was in the other direction I would
probably define less than so just just a
quick thing is that in the example one
which was P of X was the product of the
X of ice
what is my cone my cone is simply the
since the eigen values from the X it's
the X which are strictly positive so
that means that it's n+ ortant and let's
take the second example which is P of X
is X N squared minus the sum of I of X
is going from 1 to n minus 1 so in that
case the cone is just the second what's
known as the second autumn cone or at
least it's open version so that's the
SEC the set of X in RN such that in on
in RN such that xn is positive and the
sum of X I squared I 1 to n minus 1
strictly less than xn square
so that's this example from that example
so what are the acts from which the
characteristic polynomial has only
positive root so that's the the
eigenvalues must be positive so it's
going to be K plus is going to be the
set of positive definite matrices
[Applause]
definite so in this case it's going to
be K plus is going to be the set of set
of X such that
so the the
so it's the eigenvalues of some of X I a
I so it's going to be the set of X such
that sum over I of X I a I is positive
definite and so these are the hyperbolic
cones and usually we close them so
annulled if I'm going to Y by K plus
plus closure of plus and so keep so this
is K plus plus is called a spectral
agent
now a few things that I'd like to make
so let me mention a few things so first
in in in example one I had also
mentioned the case in which P of X is
the product of linear functions so when
you look at the product of linear
functions what you get is K plus is the
intersection of the half spaces defined
by these linear functions and so that's
a polygem code so any polyhedral cone
can be viewed as a hyperbolic code so
very basic result another thing that I'd
like to emphasize is that you might have
many different hyperbolic polynomials
that correspond to the same hyperbolic
code so there might be many
representations many representations of
the same hyperbolic cone so for example
second let me get back to that in a bit
late
so
so we I could have defined the
hyperbolic cone so governing so all this
is due to vomiting and he showed also
that in fact the K plus is the component
so if you look at if you if you take n
and you remove all the zeros of your
polynomial it is the connected component
that contains e so k plus is the
component on - the set of X
and and this is this is easy to see you
can exercise with this now and but the
mean what's the the main result which
makes is important from optimization is
that K plus so it's not completely
obvious so for example if you take I
mean it's definitely not obvious if you
take for example this polynomial and if
you look at the connected components
what's once you remove the zeros
definitely
these two are convex but the the
remaining is definitely not convex so
it's a it's this is this is this needs
seven exclamation mark that's a very
important very important result so let
me I'd like to show this to you it looks
like I'm going very slowly but let me
before I prove it maybe I'll prove it
either either in the break or maybe in
the second half but before I do that let
me let me mention some other ways on
that would that implies that fairly
easily so let me write that maybe as a
proposition and
will prove that later on is that in fact
this convex cone I said it depends so
these lambdas depend on the direction
I'm using E but that's not quite true in
the following sense though so let's
assume that P is homogeneous polynomial
that cycle Baalak in in direction P and
in direction e and so if if I take
another vector which is in that
hyperbolic cone then in fact then P of X
is also - Baalak in Direction F
and and k+ so if i if i put an e him to
say that i define this with respect to e
then the cone that i get with respect to
F is actually the same as the one with
respect to e and this is not surprising
once you see this so but that's that's
important too
to see but now that so let's assume that
it's hyperbolic in in in Direction F for
now and let me show that it's that you
get convexity out of it
so let's look at
let's look at my j+ place and I'd like
to show that it's convex so I'll take
two points and I'd like to show that any
any point along the line will also be in
k+ Pass now since I can since but if I
take any point I can assume that that's
the direction in which the polynomial is
hyperbolic so that means that I can
assume that let's say these are a and F
so when my polynomial is is hyperbolic
in Direction e also in directions F so
I've a of F in keep its - lets section
you want to scale + good and so now
let's look at a convex combination of
these two so let's call let's say X to
be lambda e plus 1 minus lambda F and
now I'd like to show that I need to show
that X is also X is also in Kiev in K+
so what I need to do is I need to look
at so my direction of Aipom velocity is
e so I need to look at P of X minus te
and show that the roots of that of these
univariate polynomial are all positive
so what is this X is equal to that so
that's lambda e plus 1 minus lambda f -
t e and so this is I'm going to
I'm going to let say use our ingenuity
to show that this is 1 minus lambda to
the D times the polynomial evaluated in
F minus lambda mine on t minus lambda
divided by 1 minus lambda times E I want
to show that know what I want to show
this is that X no I want to show that X
belongs in K plus because I want to show
convexity so I'm assuming that I'm
assuming is in K plus F is in K plus I
take a convex combination I'd like to
show that X also belongs to K plus so I
need to look at my direction of iPhone
velocity is e and I need to look at I
need to look at the roots of that and
show that the roots are not positive so
the roots of that and so the T such that
this is 0 but F belongs to my K plus so
it means that if I look at F minus s II
the roots of that are positive so it
means that t minus lambda divided by 1
minus lambda I'm positive
if she gives me a root here and so that
means that T is indeed positive so that
shows that the picture is not like this
and so X so that X belongs to K plus I
will I will get back to showing this and
and and relating to stability but maybe
let me let me continue a bit more so so
let me get to what what is we found to
by ipon Baalak optimization
so now that we have a convex cone this
is great because we can we can define a
convex optimization problem and use all
the machinery from convex optimization
so so if I have a hyperbolic cone K + +
I click the closed version I actually I
mean I could define it so I'm going to
look at minimizing see X sub J so so X
is in RN so this is X is e now and and
then I'm going to have that X is
supposed to be in that cone and also
some lynnium when your function also
let's say a I
Aleksey
and so this was considering this was
considered by Gullu
in 96 and also the theory was developed
also like Jim so that's that's what is
known as a hyperbolic optimization
problem and and the nice thing is that
pretty much every convex optimization
every class of convex optimization
that's known fits into that so so sorry
linear programming or linear
optimization is a special case when the
hyperbolic polynomials is the first
example the second autumn Cohen
programming is the case in which the
cone is the second golden cone which was
example two semi definite programming is
so programming semi definite programming
also over complex hermitian matrices on
Rhian symmetric matrices fits also when
[Music]
when we had the determinant of a
symmetric matrix as the hyperbolic
polynomial so it actually gives a lot of
different possibility so the exact the
exact power of hyperbolic optimization
is actually a very big open question and
it's
I will get back to that but it's not
completely clear madam its it whether it
goes beyond this DP or not but that's
that I I don't think that that's the
main the main question and I'll try to
get back to that soon so before my so
let me get back to K plus plus and
mention another view of K plus plus and
that's the following
so if I look at P of X plus TD and and
this time I'm using a plus another - so
in this case it's convenient so and it's
not D but it's e X plus te so so that's
a polynomial in T and the is going to be
P of e times T to the D and then there
will be terms long autumn tones so there
will be a TD minus one let's call that a
one of X and then there will be an a2 of
x times TD minus 2 and so on plus a D of
X which is a constant term and so let's
try to relate k plus 2 to 2 this so the
first thing to notice is that I can give
an alternate view of this because I know
that the roots of these are the lambda 1
of X lambda 2 of X and so on so this
must also be equal to the
- so it's going to be the product
of so if if this was a - it would be it
would be the lambda I of X minus T but
since it's a plus this becomes a plus so
that's the product of on the eyes and
this is PFE so this polynomial this
expression and that expression must be
the same but I can I can write this
expression in terms of symmetric the
elementary symmetric functions involving
the the roots on the eigenvalues so this
is P Fe times
T to the D plus and then we have the if
I look at this symmetric elementary
function let's go so Sigma one of the
victim of lambda times T to the D minus
one plus and so on so the general term
will be Sigma I of lambda of X times T
of D minus I and so I must have equality
between the corresponding term so the AI
of X a I of X is equal to his Sigma I of
these lambda X well that's the
elementary symmetric function
of all them i of degree of on the i in
in n variables so that's the i mean i
won't write it but you know exactly what
it is so so from that you can get a
different characterization of k plus
so which is due to when a camel and
that's saying that
the set of X such that at all I say I
effects
for example the the positive definite
matrices the matrices such that all the
elementary symmetric functions of the
eigenvalues positive and the proof is
quite simple it's it's elementary so
let's look at that capers is included in
that set so from this one so if I take
if I take an element in K plus all the
roots are positive and so if all the
words if all the roots I'm positive
clearly the sub I effects will be will
be positive as well and so that's
obvious the converse is also true
because if I take if I take an X such
that a I of X is positive Y we I then if
the I of X is positive Y we I it means
that any non negative T this is going to
be positive so that so that in price
from X such that VI of X is positive
five VI this implies that P of X plus te
is non zero and for any T that's not
negative and so that precisely means
that X is X is well so then you have to
change the sign again so you have to
change the sign so when I take but it
shows that X is indeed in the
K+ so so that shows that in fact j+ can
be viewed as the finite finite
intersection of finite intersection of
polynomial equations so it's a semi
algebraic
because it's open and keep the space is
closed
so it's from two to three so I can take
a break yeah okay questions I'm going
quite slowly so
so please elaborate on this you maybe
some comment about how we don't know if
this has more generality and there's
teepees right so let me do that after
the break maybe yeah I'll get I mean
that that's a big that's a big important
question right so so it's totally it's
on let me
okay maybe let's let me answer that
after the break any other question at
this point let's take a break so so
should I stop just from a few minutes
give some questions maybe and then yeah
the exercises yeah I yeah I don't have I
haven't prepared some very difficult
exercises so yeah maybe let's let's
pause for two or three minutes five
minutes and then I'll continue and give
exercises